[Music]
foreign
here are nine monsters bigger than
galaxies and the universe taken from
movies TV shows and other fictional
Works let's get to it at number 9 the
Maturin from Stephen King's The
Multiverse this massive turtle is an
overarching protagonist from the Stephen
King's Multiverse a turtle with an
ancient appearance Maturin existed long
before the creation of the universe by
Nature material was a kind wise gentle
compassionate benevolent and had a very
grandfather-like demeanor to humans when
he spoke to them Maturin was said to be
constantly withdrawn into his shell
Maturin is a being larger than Galaxy
clusters with the power of creation
while it otherwise known as Pennywise is
a psychic parasite that eats this
thing's vomit number 8 the extra
Galactic aliens from Men In Black these
enormous extraterrestrials are most
likely unknown to humans and potentially
even to the Men in Black it is reported
to possess marbles with what looks to be
galaxies within them one of which is the
Milky Way the alien is shown to be
toying with some of the marbles before
placing them in a bag it has a greenish
gelatinous look with four digits on each
hand with Its Reflection exposing its
face and it has three bulbous yellow
eyes in the original script of the Men
in Black these marbles actually contain
entire universes and not just galaxies
at number 7 the super Shenron from
Dragon Ball super super Shenron also
known as zalama is the Eternal dragon
that appears after the Dragon Balls the
super ones are gathered super Shenron is
a brilliant yellow dragon with gold tone
on his body with bright crimson eyes
enormous bat wings instead of the
feathery ones seen in the species he was
derived from it has no legs and spikes
around its tail he is incomprehensibly
massive proving to be many times larger
than several galaxies between universes
6 and 7. here's without a doubt the
largest Eternal dragon in the whole
Dragon Ball Saga
number six York's a thought from the
Cthulhu myths mentioned in the Dunwich
Horror jaxa thought is the greatest of
the outer Gods one of the greatest just
by definition and outer God's might is
unfathomable and unquantifiable and he
himself is omnipotent omniscient and
omnipresent his Avatar and many others
reside in the court of Azeroth in the
center of infinity yogsototh is composed
of numerous worlds and universes
resulting in an abstract look that is
hard to depict visually its Avatar seems
to be a flying shapeless creature with
several tentacles and protuberances
number five the cosmic entity is from
Marvel these Cosmic beings also known as
Cosmic entities are characters with
omnipotence Cosmic awareness and or
Universal importance they are almost
always Immortal or they are extremely
hard to kill while some of the cosmic
entities like Galactus and the
celestials are planetary in size others
such as the one above all the Living
Tribunal eternity and a couple more can
alter their size to Encompass the entire
universe while also having the ability
to watch over the Multiverse from a void
in between the universes
number four azer doth from the Cthulhu
Mythos considered as the outer Gods
ruler he is an Eldritch entity primeval
and a chaotic being that created the
cosmos and lives at its heart where he
sleeps and Slumbers and dreams to the
music of the flute playing idiot alien
servators and unending drums as Dot's
initial shape was a bivalvular shell
supported by numerous pairs of flexible
legs with many jointed cylinders topped
with polypus appendages and a horrible
Bastion mouthwash Visage with deep sung
eyes and coated in glossy black hair his
present form though is envisioned to be
much more terrible
number three the anti-spiral from gurin
Lagan the anti-spiral is both the leader
and a physical manifestation of the
anti-spiral tribe's Consciousness after
they sealed themselves away to purge
their rays of spiral power a source of
Limitless energy that one day will
evolve into a spiral Nemesis and become
the destruction of existence this living
Shadow the collective of the anti-spiral
tribes Consciousness is stated to be 52
billion light years tall which means
it's more than half the size of the
current observable universe that is
currently estimated to be 93 billion
light years across number two super
tangent topper gun Lagan informally
known as sttgl this is a colossal
mecca-like mass of energy formed during
the final battle with the anti-spiral in
the second movie adaptation of the
series the lights in the Sky are Stars
it appears to be a gunman with a blue
colored Universe shaped into a body
surrounding what seems to be its bones
it also has star-shaped sunglasses and a
red cape the size of sttgl is larger
than the observable universe estimates
for its height range from at least
348.48 billion light years to 10.45
trillion light years tall way taller
than the anti-spiral
and number one the leviathans from
Doctor Who these leviathans are vast
transcendental entities who live in the
void between universes in comparison
universes shatter against their sights
like bubbles against the sides of a
whale they are also sometimes referred
to as the intercreationals they were
incapably large being the size of
multiple universes together the typical
Universe there in that franchise have a
circumference of around 157 billion
light years across while an average
Leviathan was said to be 150 quadrillion
light years long making a single
Leviathan more than 3 million times
bigger in overall volume than a single
universe
so that's it the nine monsters bigger
than galaxies and universes so I hope
you have enjoyed watching this video do
hit the like button for support and
subscribe but most of all smash the Bell
icon for regular updates on new videos
right here on this channel till the next
one take care fam